- [Interviewer] All right, Valentina.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Valentina,
where are you from,
where'd you grow up?
- [Valentina] Uh, I grew up in Miami,
up until I was 18
and then I left to New
York as soon as I could.
- [Interviewer] And you're
living in Los Angeles currently?
- Yeah, I've been out here
for the past five years or so.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood,
you had both your parents
when you were young?
- Uh, yeah, I had both my parents, um,
they divorced when I was 18,
they did that thing where like
they never liked each other,
but they stayed together
'cause they had kids
and yeah, but I had both of them.
I still do.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- Um, (sighs)
they did the best that they could,
given the tools that they
had, and um, yeah, I think--
- [Interviewer] That's
a good way of seeing it.
- Yeah. (laughs)
I mean, I don't like
blame them for anything.
My mom was always angry, so,
even my dad would be like scared of her.
She would yell a lot and,
but besides that, I mean,
I just got like the,
I would get hit, but I mean,
nothing like out the--
- Nothing terrible?
- No no, nothing too terrible.
- Yeah.
- No.
- [Interviewer] And what kind of a kid
were you in high school?
- Oh, I was bad. (laughs)
I was really bad.
Yeah, in high school, I guess,
I don't know, the hormones and also Miami,
I don't think is like the
best place to raise a child,
I would say, there's
a lot of drugs and uh,
yeah so in high school,
I experimented a lot with drugs and uh,
I had a lot of sex.
Uh,
but, yeah, I would skip class.
I didn't finish high school.
Around 16 I was like, I'm
gonna join the military.
I thought that would be
a good idea. (laughs)
So uh,
I didn't follow through with it,
I got in an argument with the recruiter
and then that was it.
But I got my GED and then I tried college,
but yeah, high school, just bad. (laughs)
I tried um,
first it was weed,
then I tried coke and then I did uh,
acid, shrooms, pills,
pretty much everything
except like the hard stuff, like,
I never wanted to get lost
and I was scared of getting lost, so,
but thankfully, I don't have
like an addictive personality,
so nothing stuck.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, and
today you're just doing
pot you said?
- Uh yeah, like a couple times a year,
for like celebratory reasons.
- [Interviewer] So drugs
are not really a part of your life now?
- No, maybe like two
glasses of wine a week
or something like that--
- Yeah.
And what kind of work have
you done since school?
- Everything.
So, waitressing,
stripping,
I went to school for two years
and I became an ultrasound tech.
So I'm currently doing
that during the day.
But yeah, I've had probably
over 30 jobs at this point.
- [Interviewer] So you
have a straight job.
- Yeah.
- As an ultrasound tech--
- [Interviewer] And then what
do you do with your other,
when you're not working that job?
- School. (laughs)
I'm in school
and then also I see men on the side.
Uh, professional men, I guess.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
so this is through like,
websites and things like that?
- Mmhmm, yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you would
call yourself an escort?
- Uh, I'd call myself
a sex worker, but yeah,
essentially, it's escorting.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Mmhmm.
- Sex worker
is such a vague term, I
have a hard time using it.
- Well because I've uh,
gone through other mediums or ways,
I just, because I've done
stripping and web camming and um,
escorting, and sometimes just uh,
just straight up prostitution.
I mean, not like on the street,
but yeah so, I just say sex
work 'cause I've done it all.
- [Interviewer] Mmhmm.
How does stripping compare
to working as an escort?
- So with stripping, you have to,
you have to have a good
mouthpiece, (laughs) I would say
and I don't have that.
I'd rather um,
the person knows what they
want, I know what I want
and then we just get it
over with and go home,
our separate ways.
With stripping, you're
there at least five hours
and I would come out of there with,
maybe $600, but that's
also because I wasn't like
doing anything in the back, I guess.
I was just dancing, mostly,
'cause I didn't wanna talk--
- [Interviewer] A lot
of girls will do things
in the back rooms?
- Yeah, all the time, yeah.
I worked in strip clubs in Miami
and then also in New York.
The ones out here aren't really that good,
so I never did it out here.
But um, yeah, it's tiring and exhausting.
It wears on your body
and everyone's smoking
and you just go home
and you feel like shit the next day.
Yeah, so.
With escorting, it's a quick one hour
and it's the same money.
Like, I have a minimum, like I
won't leave unless it's $500,
preferably more than that, but for an hour
and then I go home and I
don't have to think about it
until next week, so.
- [Interviewer] Are there
dangers in working as an escort
where you're probably picking up
a higher caliber of customer
than working the street?
- Um, (sighs)
yeah, working the street,
I've never considered doing--
- [Instructor] Right, that's another--
- I never felt like I had to.
So, I mean, everyone does things
'cause they feel like they have to do it.
Like if I ever felt like I
had to, I would, but um--
- [Interviewer] I think that's a much more
treacherous lifestyle
than what you're doing.
- Yeah, for sure.
- [Interviewer] But are there dangers
in what you're doing as well?
- Um, I've only had one
terrible experience,
like it wasn't even, I
mean, I got drugged, but um,
nothing
worse than that.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How would you describe
most of your clientele?
- Uh, (sighs)
rich, old, white men. (laughs)
They either have their own businesses
or engineers, you know,
just, they're normal,
they're just lonely, mostly.
- [Interviewer] Are they married?
- Some of them, yeah.
I actually ended up having
like a three-year relationship
with one, like a normal--
- [Interviewer] Romantic?
- Relationship.
- Where you,
you actually liked him and he liked you?
- Yeah, um,
he was married
uh, had kids and everything, so
it's not like we were going
in with those expectations,
but that's just what happened.
- [Interviewer] Was it a
sugar daddy relationship?
- Yeah.
- It was, so--
- mmhmm.
- [Interviewer] You didn't truly,
I mean, it's a fine line and
it gets blurred all the time
where, were you in love
with him, were you--
- No, we were in love, we
lived together and everything.
He was just helping me out
with like $2,000 a month,
that's not enough to like (laughs)
make me
stay, you know?
Like I gave up a lot of things.
- [Interviewer] That
would mean I've got about
30 of those kind of relationships
going right now. (laughs)
- Yeah. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] And where do you see
your life going from here?
- Um, well like I said, I'm in school,
so graduate school,
um,
that's a good question, I mean, I don't,
I try not to think too much--
- [Interviewer] How old are you?
- I'm 25.
- [Interviewer] 25, so you're very young--
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You can go
in any direction from here,
but this lifestyle that you're living,
I mean, what comes along with it?
Are there emotions that
it brings up or is there--
- Uh-- (sighs)
- [Interviewer] When you're by yourself,
do you sometimes have feelings that
come from doing this kind of work?
- Only if
only during,
usually not when I'm by myself.
When I'm by myself, I like to like,
compartmentalize, like,
I'm like, that's what I do for money
'cause I'm only doing it,
'cause with my job, I make enough
to like support myself and
live a normal life, I guess.
- [Interviewer] Are you saving money?
- Uh, I'm trying to, but the thing is,
I take care of my mom and then
I also take care of my sister.
So I'm like financially supporting them.
- [Interviewer] So between
your job and your side job--
- Yeah, I'm supporting three people, so.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, right.
- Um,
yeah, so I'm trying to save money,
but it's impossible. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] Yeah, life gets expensive.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Does your
family know you're doing this?
- Um, (sighs)
I think my dad knows that I was stripping,
but no.
- [Interviewer] So now you're
gonna do a video on YouTube--
(Valentina laughs)
- Yeah, I'm trying to
live more openly, I guess,
and honestly and
I don't think that,
I mean, they would prefer I wouldn't.
- [Interviewer] Of course, yeah.
- But um,
I think they just love me and.
- [Interviewer] Your motive seems to be
to help support your family.
- Yeah, mainly.
- [Interviewer] Which is noble, right?
- Mmhmm.
Yeah, I'm not out here buying,
like, Louis Vuitton bags
and driving a BMW or anything like that.
It's just um, what I
feel like I have to do.
- Right.
- But, I mean,
it does get in the way of me having like
a normal relationship, I guess.
- [Interviewer] Does it?
- Mmhmm.
- [Interviewer] I would
think most guys that might
want a relationship with
you would have a hard time
with you doing that at night.
- Some guys don't mind.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
I'm sure there's (laughs)
and there's always exceptions
to everything I say, right.
- Yeah.
Some guys don't mind, but um,
yeah, it's not like an ideal situation.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I would
think I'd have a hard time
if you were my girlfriend
and you're going off
to entertain three guys tonight.
- (laughs) Well,
currently, I'm only seeing
one person, once a week.
But sometimes, I'll have like,
I guess regulars, that would like come--
- [Interviewer] Come and go.
- Yeah, they'll just like text me randomly
and then maybe in a month
I'll see like three guys.
That's it.
- Mmhmm.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Is there
shame that comes up from this?
- Uh-- (sighs)
- [Interviewer] You know,
sex work and shame seem
to go together, so.
I'm not saying there should be.
- I'm sure people (laughs)
I'm sure people think whatever
they want of me, but um,
I don't feel that way.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
You just feel like you're doing
what you have to do to survive.
- Yeah.
- Pretty much.
And it's not like
uh, I'm stealing or robbing or you know,
like tricking anyone into anything.
- [Interviewer] No, you're
providing a service and--
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's an
agreement on both sides, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Do you respect
the guys that pick you up?
- (laughs) Um,
well I'm in school for psychology, so--
- [Interviewer] Oh you are.
- Yeah. (laughs)
So from like the human perspective,
I try to understand and
respect them to an extent--
- [Interviewer] Mmhmm.
- As far as like, you
know, they're lonely,
they have whatever issues
they have going on,
like I hear them out, I'm like
their therapist sometimes.
- Sure.
- But um--
- [Interviewer] Do you
have guys that pick you up
and will not want sex,
they just wanna have a couple
hours with you or whatever?
- Guys always want sex. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] They do? (laughs)
I get so many girls that tell
me the guys don't want sex
and I'm like, "Really?"
- They have a good mouthpiece probably.
I don't, like--
- Oh I see.
- (laughs) I mean, I'm an
amazing listener, but um,
no, everyone wants to have sex, I think.
What was the question? (laughs)
- [Interviewer] No, just uh--
- Do I respect them?
- [Interviewer] Do you
respect the men that
are your customers?
- Uh, yeah, from a
human perspective, I do,
but as far as myself, no.
Like-- (laughs)
- [Interviewer] You wouldn't
want them for partners?
- God no, they're disgusting. (laughs)
Like um,
yeah, I don't
respect people who can't be
like honest with themselves.
Yeah.
Like it's one thing to lie to your wife
and lie to your friends or whatever,
but they're just lying to themselves, so,
yeah, they're nasty, like, (laughs)
they're just um,
yeah, I don't know,
no, the clear answer is no. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I sense that.
Do you believe in love?
- [Valentina] Uh, I believe in love.
- [Interviewer] You do?
- [Valentina] Yeah.
Uh I don't think that
love is just one like,
sole definition.
Like the people I love the
most would be my sister,
number one, and then probably my mom.
My mom and I have just been through a lot,
particularly, like after
after her separation from like my dad,
she ended up losing her dad,
her mom and her best friend,
like around the same time
and then she lost the house,
she lost her job
and then she just like lost her mind,
her sanity pretty much.
She's always been like schizophrenic,
like I remember when I was younger,
she would tell me, like,
that I had special eyes
and that I can like look at the sun
for like a really long time.
Yeah, (laughs) and she would um,
she would just do some weird stuff,
but for the most part, it
was like under control,
but then after the divorce, like,
uh, yeah, she lost everything.
She like attempted suicide multiple times.
I like left New York to come stay with her
to like take care of her
and the first night we
got like an apartment.
She like jumped off of the second floor,
like right in front of me.
Yeah, that really messed
me up for a long time.
But yeah, she's older,
so she broke like her hip
and had to get multiple surgeries
and she's been in and out
of like mental hospitals
for the past uh,
seven years, I guess.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
So,
but the way that it's
affected me, I guess, um,
I've kinda just been
following like her, I guess,
her footsteps, in a way.
Like uh,
not schizophrenia, no, (laughs)
not as far as I'm concerned, but um,
in October, I ended up going
to the psychiatric ward
for like a suicide attempt
and um,
yeah, just like a lot of
generational depression
in my family, I would say.
- [Interviewer] Do you
think that's like, just
brain chemistry or is it something that--
- I think so.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause
the first time I felt depressed
I was like in forth grade.
I just remember like crying in my room
and I couldn't like explain
like why I was crying.
There was no reason
behind it, I was just sad.
- [Interviewer] The more I do these talks,
the more I see that brain chemistry
is a big part of the puzzle.
- Yeah.
- Of everything that,
you hear these people struggling with.
- Mmhmm.
- [Interviewer] All of us.
- Yeah.
Yeah, so I think (sighs)
uh, yeah, I've had depression
for the most part of my life.
Now it's okay 'cause after
I went to the hospital,
they put me on medication,
so it's, I'm doing better.
- [Interviewer] Does this
work you do affect you,
do you think?
- Um--
- I mean,
does it make depression more,
make you more prone to feeling depressed?
I mean, if you believe in love--
- Mmhmm.
- [Interviewer] But then you're
selling yourself for money,
at some point there's a
conflict there that comes up.
- It is difficult because I appreciate,
like selling yourself
and not just your body
because it is like
you're selling your time,
you're selling uh,
like a part of your soul, in a way.
- [Interviewer] I didn't
wanna say those words,
but that's kinda what
I'm referring to, yeah.
- Um, (laughs)
yeah, uh, I guess it does.
And like the more you--
- [Interviewer] I mean,
I work as a photographer
for advertising, so when
I do that for money,
as I did yesterday,
I feel like I'm selling myself.
- Mmhmm.
- Just like an escort
would be selling herself.
- We're all
prostituting ourselves. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] I totally see that
and I believe it's all the same thing.
- Yeah.
Um,
yeah, I mean, it does affect me
negatively, I would say, uh,
but I have
reasons and I have,
you know, that's why I,
I suggest, like anyone
who's looking to do this,
like to actually have like,
maybe not a career, but like an actual job
and like something to
look forward to and like,
positive people in your life because--
- [Interviewer] Do you enjoy your day job?
- Um, (laughs)
I do because I like helping people.
Like, I like that human connection.
But it's not like what I wanna do
for the rest of my life, for sure.
Yeah, my goal is to be a therapist, so.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Yeah.
Just because, I mean,
I've been around, like
crazy people (laughs)
and broken individuals my whole life,
including myself, so.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I think we all are.
- Yeah.
We all just demonstrate
it in different ways.
- [Interviewer] And the ones who deny it
are the ones that are probably
the worst off. (laughs)
(Valentina laughing)
- Yeah, I think everyone needs therapy,
like, at least at one point in their life
for whatever period that is, but um,
it's very, at least for
me, it's been very helpful.
- [Interviewer] What have
you learned about men
by doing this kind of work?
The sex work?
- Uh, (sighs)
not much, to be honest with you--
- [Interviewer] 'Cause it's
not all men that do this,
that will hire a prostitute.
- Um--
- [Interviewer] It's only
a certain segment of the--
- I feel like I've
known men my whole life.
Like,
it's not, you don't learn anything
that you don't already know.
(pair laughing)
Um,
yeah, uh--
- [Interviewer] One of the
interviews I did last week,
I asked the girl this question
and she said, "Men are dogs. (laughs)
"That's what I've learned."
- It's uh,
yeah, but some are loyal, you know,
some dogs are loyal. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] For sure some are, yeah.
- Some are loyal, some
are cuter than others,
some, you know, won't
hump you in your sleep,
but for the most part, yeah, I guess.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it's a wide range.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- I've learned that.
Yeah, but I just, you know,
because you work as an escort
and have this background,
it's interesting to get
your perspective on it.
- Yeah, no, I had an introduction to men
at a very young age.
Like, I don't know if
it's the sole reason,
but like I guess my
introduction to like sex work
started at like 12, pretty much.
- [Interviewer] How'd that happen?
- Um, (sighs)
I had a best friend in middle school,
her dad, at the time,
I was like 12 and he was like
uh, I don't know, like in his 50's maybe,
or like late 40's, or something like that,
he
you want like the full story? (laughs)
- [Interviewer] Well,
share as much as your comfortable sharing.
- Sure, I mean, it's just like--
- [Interviewer] You can
simplify it if that helps.
- Okay.
I mean it's just like 10 years of stuff.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah.
But I can--
- [Interviewer] That
the sexual relationship
with your friend's dad?
- We only had sex one time.
But um,
yeah, like he met me and I guess,
pretty much like fell in love with me and
he was being uh,
sentenced to prison.
He lived in California
and I was in Miami and uh,
he came down to see his daughter
and I might not be getting
all the details right,
so like, they're part,
but from my perspective,
this is what happened and um,
he was being sentenced to prison
so he wanted to see her like one last time
'cause he was gonna go for
three years or four years,
whatever it was.
He met me on his birthday,
which is October 1st,
and I say this because October 1st
there's just a lot of stuff
happens on October 1st,
for some reason, for me.
(sighs) So, (laughs) I meet him,
he falls in love with me, essentially,
we maintain touch for like,
so I can keep him updated
on his daughter or whatever.
He ends up like calling me,
we used to talk on the phone all the time.
He would send me like
love letters from prison.
- [Interviewer] From prison?
- From prison, yeah.
He would send me poems and stuff.
Then he got out, um,
we maintained touch, he
would fly back and forth,
to like come see me, um,
uh, (sighs)
I think I was like 16 and
this was like the time
I was gonna go to the military, so,
he like got a hotel for us
and bought me like, all this lingerie
and I just felt like really uncomfortable
'cause like I
I didn't like, I wasn't attracted to him.
I didn't like feel that for him,
but at the time, I felt like,
I don't know, I felt kinda
trapped, like I didn't
have any like choices.
- [Interviewer] Mmhmm.
- Really, 'cause he was scary. (laughs)
Like he ended up getting um,
like my name, my initials,
like my lips, a portrait of
me, like tattooed on him.
He has like my mom's initials,
like he's not like a sane person. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] But this all began,
not sexually, but the
romantic part of it for him
sounded like it started when you were 12?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Um,
he would like ask me
for like nudes and stuff
and I was like,
$50. (laughs)
Like, I would sell him my
nudes for like $50 and um,
at the time, like that's a lot of money
for like a, I guess I was
like 14 at this time, or 15.
Yeah, but back to the
night with the hotel,
and I just felt trapped, and he was like,
"Okay, that's fine, we can
go home, I'll take you home."
But my parents didn't know I was with him,
obviously, so I'm like,
"No, I can't go home,
"like I have to stay."
And um,
yeah, we had sex,
um,
for like a minute and then
I started crying. (laughs)
And
in my mind, I was just like, uh, (laughs)
not that I deserve this, but I guess like,
in a way, like, I put
myself in this situation,
like no one told me to do this.
Like, I'm here, like, I guess.
Um,
I guess this is what I deserve, I guess.
Like,
it's the way that my mind like--
- [Interviewer] Would you
say it was your environment,
was it your brain chemistry,
was it something that
happened in your childhood,
what would you say
opened the door for that?
Or was it just he just pressured you?
Or pursued you so heavily?
- Yeah, he would just make me feel bad,
like manipulate me into
into feeling like this is what I--
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that's
what it kinda sounds like.
- Yeah, 'cause he was like 50
something and I was like 15.
But um,
yeah, and then fast forward
he would send letters to my dad's house
and like, you know,
send bouquets, like edible
arrangements to like my job
and like just show up and um,
when I got in that
relationship with that man
that turned into a
three-year relationship, um,
he helped me, like get a restraining order
'cause I just couldn't do it.
Like in my mind, I was like, I can't,
like he's gonna go back to prison,
like something's gonna happen to,
like it was like a
a weird dynamic like where
I didn't want him to get in trouble.
Like, I cared for him
even though like,
he was (laughs)
threatening me all the time and um,
stalking me, whatever.
I don't know what it's called, but yeah.
Just making my life very difficult.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Being an attractive female
has it's burdens, doesn't it?
- I don't consider myself uh,
attractive, like-- (laughs)
- [Interviewer] You don't?
- No, I like,
consider myself neutral, I guess,
'cause I'm just myself and this is,
I mean, I definitely
use it to my advantage
to get money and whatever--
- [Interviewer] Right.
- But um,
like when I go home and
like take my makeup off
and I'm just there by myself,
like I'm not like, oh,
I'm so pretty. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] You don't
see yourself that way?
- No, I just see myself as
normal, like a person. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] That's
probably a healthy attitude,
but you are beautiful--
- Thank you.
- you should
see yourself that way.
But what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- Um, (sighs)
I mean, I had a negative view of life for,
up until a couple months ago, so,
I guess, just to be present.
Like right now, I'm not thinking like,
when I leave here or I'm
not thinking like before,
I'm just like right now,
this is what's happening.
And uh,
yeah, just trying to be present.
- [Interviewer] That's good.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's a great one.
- Thanks. (laughs)
- [Interviewer] All right, Valentina,
thank you so much for sharing your story
and I wish you the best
of luck with school
and your two careers.
- (laughs) Thank you so much.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.
That was great.